the president took to twitter this
morning writing that our state is quote
a cesspool of fake votes end quote
this comes as the clark county registrar
addressing the continuing vote count as
well as fraud
8 news now reporter joe mohler is live
outside the election center with what
he's learned today
joe
the votes will continue to be counted
through thursday of the week this week
the registrar of voters here in clark
county says
he is confident in the process in the
elections department here through the
past week or so and he says
he's confident through these allegations
that continue to surface now what is
left to count here are a few thousand
cured ballots those are the ones that
need id verification or signature
validation
in addition to that there are sixty
thousand provisional ballots that still
need to be reviewed by the secretary of
state's office
those will be in by thursday now today
on twitter president trump claimed there
is a substantial amount of voter fraud
in nevada
this includes an allegation that at
least two votes were cast on behalf of
dead people in clark county
the registrar of voters responded to the
campaign's allegations
we have sent information to the
secretary of state to have an
investigative team
they are currently looking into quite a
few things
for those folks in the general public we
have the data so if there's anything
that's been done
illegally unfortunately we're going to
we're going to find it
[Music]
now gloria says he does trust the
election process and the integrity of it
as far as mail ballots go those will
continue to come in
and they will through tomorrow but today
only a few dozen were received here at
the election center now updates will
start happening
only once a day they did switch it to
twice a day but since there's less mail
ballots coming into the elections
department they're now going back
to once a day until these votes are all
counted on thursday reporting live north
las vegas joe moeller 8 news now
the